كانت اول قمه دوليه تعقد في مولدوفا البلد
الصغير والمتصدر للائحه الدول الافقر في
اوروبا وكانت اول قمه اوروبيه تعقد في بلد
ليس عضوا في الاتحاد الاوروبي الهدف ارسال
رساله قويه الى روسيا مفادها ان مولدوفا
ليست وحدها كما قال قاده اوروبيون تعاقبوا
على الكلام طلب زيلينسكي ضمانات امنيه
وقال ان الوقت قد حان لاتخاذ قرارات واضحه
الامنيه مهمه جدا ليس فقط من اجل اوكرانيا
بل ايضا من اجل جيرانها ومن اجل مولدوفا
واحتمالات العدوان على مولدوفا واجزاء
اخرى من اوروبا الرئيس الفرنسي امامويل
ماكرون قال ان بلاده ستواصل دعم اوكرانيا
عسكريا لتمكينها من شن الهجوم المضاد على
روسيا
اعتقد ان قمه المقبل يجب ان تبعث رساله
واضحه الى اوكرانيا والاوكرانيين وقد
اتفقت مع الرئيس زيلينسكي على مواصله دعم
بلاده بالاسلحه كانت قمه بولبوا مناسبه
للقاء جمع ايضا كلا من الرئيس الفرنسي
ومستشار المانيا برئيس وزراء ارمينيا
والرئيس الادربيجاني كما التقى ماكرون
رئيسه وزراء كوسوفو والرئيسه الصربي داعيا
بعد اللقاء الى تطبيق خطه فرنسيه المانيه
لتهدئه التوترات في كوسوفو ابرزت هذه
القمه تباين المواقف بين الاوروبيين داخل
الاتحاد وخارجه الى حد الاختلاف احيانا
وان حافظوا على وحده ظاهريه من بريطانيا
المؤيده لهجمات اوكرانيا في العمق الروسي
الى هولندا والدممارك المتحمسه لتدريب
طيارين اوكرانيين مرورا بالمانيا غير
المتحمسه لانضمام كياف الى حلف الناتو
ووصولا الى فرنسا التي تحاول بصعوبه
التوفيق بين دعمها المتردد لزلانسكي
ورغبتها الضمنيه في لحظه حوار متجدده مع
بوتين
العربيه بول بوكا مولدوفا لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات